I'm gonna get my ass killed here oh yeah
the other thing about blood I forgot to
say is that it's hard as balls hello
welcome to random encounter the sort of
weekly livestream show where I play a
different random video game this is the
last random encounter for a couple of
weeks because I'm going off to Ireland
where I'll be randomly encountering
newborn children I've not met and
alcohol over the course of a couple of
weeks I'm also going to London which
will be similar without the newborn
babies and then Germany which will be
replaced newborn babies were pork
knuckle and retain alcohol throughout
the entire thing and that's my next
couple of weeks but you don't care when
you will character with the gamescom
stuff cuz you might actually see that on
the website but in terms of random
encounter we're going out with a banger
I have not played this game since about
the Year k-mer in 1997 this is blood and
blood is is a game that I feel a lot of
people don't know or like whenever I
mention it in terms of like the the like
the the history of first-person shooters
it's sort of this like weird lost childs
and nobody a lot of people don't seem to
know but the people who do know what I
like oh you have [ __ ] blood it's the
one where you can kick heads and throw
dynamite and shoot people with flare
guns and stuff and this is made by
monolith productions who you probably
know mostly for I guess the fear series
and I mean most guys are still around I
think this might use the same engine as
Duke Nukem because it was produced in
partnership with 3d realms and it's kind
of like it's kind of like Duke Nukem
meats like hexon or something it's got
this like a cult II weird weapons thing
going on and the best part of it
actually is if you buy this on gog.com
it straight up runs and like
high-resolution really good look at this
dude is nonsense
all right so we're gonna jump straight
in I have not played I'm legitimately
not played this game since I was about
nine years old so I have no idea what to
do look at this every kid look like a
doomed is it just it made every single
game use weird cheese wash wait was that
oh that's the episodes okay
and here's the difficulty lightly
broiled why not I don't have a map just
popped up there for a second oh wow
cutscene it looks super janky I do not
remember cutscenes
you didn't Kate oh god he's gonna light
you get more thanks Mimi faster yeah
what's wrong with your fairies I didn't
think this game had a story I preferred
it when I didn't think I had a story
he's weird baby man getting attacked by
spiders well I like the bad blood was
that they just kind of threw you into a
cemetery
you just started killing [ __ ] your
princess is in another castle I got it
no here we go what the notice map follow
mode buzz okay for some reason it
spawned me in map mode and as mayor
sensitivity needs fixin I don't actually
member ever playing this with the mouse
so perhaps
no mass sensitivity controls here we go
invert Mouse aim on oh my god who the
[ __ ] made this nope
nice little saves yes
Oh No invert Maris needs to be washed
Jesus Christ that's not what invert mask
means video game just turn on invert
Mouse all right I'm putting this up to
the top so here we go
great start with a pitchfork super dark
you get this guy oh yeah yeah I remember
remember playing this with mass this is
very much a cursor keys and mossad
situation
died when I remember about this game and
how it differentiated itself from other
games was the demand of Gore happening
you can also hit the heads I think
there's a kick button oh yeah
just kick him that way look hey hey
there they go blood still coming out of
it and I guess there's a nine year old
child this was pretty incredible right
now not so much
but this gates locked
god it's so dark the bit where I put the
gamma oh yeah here we go that's better
yeah maybe that's a bit too much gamma
hey there I just remember everything
being at like way more being interactive
interactable than other games I wish
this gate was more interactable
yes dude hey I got the flare gun
you can Benchley they go on fire there
you go I think he would just shoot them
and let them stay there for a while
that's just person the flames yeah there
you go
it's [ __ ] monk this is it all the way
him on it as well look at that bet the
key I got the skull key
I think some of these broke up or
something
I'm just getting flashbacks to like nine
year old me oh wise their heart oh you
eat hearts of course you do
kick the heads all right I don't change
weapons
go check the controls before I started
jump Crouch run order one weapon fire
weapons special fire X all right a
special weapon dynamite I feel like I
might be nope oh yes I love us it is a
doom
it is the wolf or friggin Duke Nukem
maker I used to love doing this because
it just made your framerate looks like
friggin great I don't know why the frame
rates not great considering we're
running this on space-age technology as
far as this game is concerned but
whatever okay Oh [ __ ] maps remember
this this is okay this is 100%
absolutely the Duke Nukem engine here
yeah I'm gonna get my ass killed here oh
yeah the other thing about blood I
forgot to say is that it's hard as balls
and also there's no auto say if I can
hear tomahawks like screaming in his
head but I didn't say for any states
it's okay we're back here
now that guy again stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop look how
good is that scream real nasty they're
gone
I shoot you once what you gonna fire
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's so good every time it's
hilarious that guys wearing a cloak he
should go on fire super quick y'all go
on fire
yeah there's definitely some older way
and business going on here yeah I don't
know I don't know that's pretty great I
go in here
it's stuck
save
thanks that
all right I do need to find out what the
goddamn L change weapon is it's the
number key it's not Oh a date sorry it's
just it's just a dynamite as six yeah
fair no oh I'll try not to blow myself
obviously
I won't try that hard though hey what's
up guys eat that pretty great
oh it's not that I'm here a flesh wound
yeah there die monk you think shouting
motherlover oh [ __ ] what's going on who
shoot me
god this game is so hard
all right when I ran out of dynamite so
I guess I'm boned why did I not get the
or I got shotgun shells do I have a
shotgun I don't think I have a shotgun
nope all right I need to get out of here
whatever if it's so freaky and jump up
there of course I can [ __ ] I forgot
this is a game made in 1997 or 99 cents
up this could not have comment like I
said why am I saying that nice effort
this must have come in earlier than 97
it's couldn't come at a year before
half-life warm wasn't dewpt:19 hmm are
you an explosive barrel or your barrel
full of friendly gifts let's find out
explosive barrel uh goddammit
hey what's up I got a pitchfork oh Jesus
Christ
what happened there oh he's got grenades
I just kicked the head at him it's so
hard find it hard this was yeah grenades
straight away I'm gonna fly him I got a
case of TNT I got a case at a TI T's
gonna play the organ and
oh I got Beast vision I don't know what
the hell that is but I bet it works my
press ENTER oh no it doesn't stick [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here
oh [ __ ] give us a word
I remember being this hard I also don't
remember this level thanks for helping
that's a great screen that's the that's
a way better screen that's such a nasty
script oh look all the stuff in here
save oh [ __ ] I was almost the world's
worst autosave or quick save what I bet
that's not a language I bet that's
that's just one of the designers going
[ __ ] what is mice there's frigging mice
attacking me what all right
all right I'm gonna leave him there for
a second I'm gonna go over here and get
me some friggin tnt case myself a case
of TN t--'s I'll just rats here as well
look at them all
[ __ ] rats Kawai all right I'm T&T
oh they would die rats
all right
oh it phantom what was that what was
that button f1 hey what's up mine okay
video games are weird okay it's likely
through envy inventory items I don't
have anymore
oh I thought they were pickups the only
reason that came in here all your fault
also yours waste Oh what's this
I got the dagger key that sound like
Homer Simpson
take that stupid Church sorry to any
church-going people here I'm not giving
it about churches in general just this
one this one sucks all I've got is TNT
so I'm just gonna keep keep throwing TNT
so like win the video game I use this
switch boom old man dude I was playing
football with your buddy's head how do
you like that I play football with your
head next I'm gonna lineal Messi you
uh-huh where's it gone where's his head
so hard to kill sprites in the 3d
environments I turn on the splice which
I'm pretty sure that is the exact light
switch that's in Duke Nukem 3d I have
been wrong before
each division where do I go next [ __ ]
rats where did you come from did you
come from somewhere or turn the lights
on here
I opened something back here stuck still
stuck
hey rats it's gonna run past all of you
all you came from under there I got the
flares are golf there's [ __ ] oh oh hello
oh just up here again alright alright
consult the map its slide in that
courtyard I guess
nope well that's gonna do is invite all
the rats to come up here you can't walk
upstairs right ha stupid rats where yeah
[ __ ] hey there don't make me use TNT on
you I can't afford to walk it's so hard
it's like that phrase shooting fish in a
barrel it's not actually that easy to
shoot a fish once it's in a bar Oh cuz
they're all squiggly and the bullets
aren't that big like it is shooting fish
in the barrel is as difficult if not
harder than pitch forking rats in a
cemetery that should be the new phrase
all right is this the door actually
that's the door isn't it that's the door
whoo nope
huh
[ __ ] why am I even doing I walk around
take the scenic route
magic door open yeah save yeah all right
I got more flares
I remember games of this ilk having so
much ammo conservation oh I did a really
bad job at dodging ham
oh Jesus I need health eat that yep
dad I'm at that that'll do it
hit the switch to end the level this
might as well be do that's great
level two that's a great the dead I'll
remember this I remember this I remember
being super Jobs whatever we've got here
[ __ ] you you can't hit me I'm up here
you can't hit me you're running away
because of AI or because he's just I
love that sense so much LEvolution
more barrels of fun look at all these
dead dudes and barrels fresh tumors for
the ever growing army of the undead
what there's weird your tax dollars at
work
Department of Transportation track
replacement for it what I thought this
is in some sort of Hell world don't you
love when they added mass support to
these games and that's just your
perspective is just like what's going on
there wha many mushrooms I think that's
more explosions oh [ __ ] that does
explode oh I'm wasting all my ammo
oh Jesus I've got one left yet
I gotta be killing her ent I know Mike
oh hello shotgun oh hello
dude all right I could have done a
better job with my TMC anyway so hey
what's up what's up what's up hey check
out this pitchfork I've got look at it
just the tip check it out yeah yeah
where my flares gone again didn't I pick
up flares I'll use the flares [ __ ] this
game this is [ __ ]
how much if I didn't have the ammo could
I like to not get past this part yeah
stops bloating fresh victims for the
ever growing army of the undead I'll do
it
oh [ __ ]
brains brains yeah you need brains every
once in a while there's one of these
turn into an actual dude no I got a
shotgun the words of John McClane
boom boom oh these dudes you just went
prone oh no I'm not using that again see
your dumb ass holding onto my shut ease
I'll using a strafing skills to murder
you
I guess I never really knew when like
blood was set like what era what like
universe or anything oh [ __ ] bats
hate bats I'm not gonna be able to kill
you with dynamite you gonna hurt me
hey what's up yeah your bats went
outside yeah no I didn't kill them
[ __ ] screen god damn it guys didn't
even invite me to this undead party
thing I got pretty good at dodging these
guys that'll be honest II may be the
best person playing blood in the world
at the moment I [ __ ] love that over I
just badly compressed just awful peaking
scream noise yo what's up I [ __ ] knew
you were there I'm gonna got 12 health
you dildo I got more now save oh you've
absolutely granado's sorbet i give you a
[ __ ] Granado sorbet are these dudes
are they just regular humans hey you
gonna you're ice yeah you probably
should get the [ __ ] out of here
this is great
look at this dude yeah I'd be freaked
there too and my underpants oh they're
like the like not undead versions of
these dudes
what should I kill these humans will
they return as other things they're
checking that pitchfork you just say go
away
now poke your friend where's your friend
gun hey check out my pitch for all this
stuck up here that's tragic hey what's
up Oh way that's really good at dodging
oh that's kind of dark I kind of feel
bad oh [ __ ]
lover they just run past you
who the [ __ ] is doing that oh he's in
there
Oh to you Jesus Christ he's guys coming
to nowhere yeah there's something medium
difficulty right yeah that's right when
somebody shoots you run towards them
good call that's why you're in this
situation idiot yeah that's right I
remembered you this time
alright on the body play football with
me hey play soccer with me come on you'd
be on gold that's the goal okay that's
the goal down there
you're on gold I scored [ __ ] a football
not sure if I should save here I won't
say buy the old video one put
I'll run in do this [ __ ] BAM
oh there's too many of them in here this
is [ __ ]
alright you know what I need this is a
first-person shooter that came out in
stupid years so I'm gonna look up cheats
good friends at gamefaqs cbsi family of
video game websites also what why is the
Comic Con thing here as well I made this
video in like 50 minutes I what the [ __ ]
it's alright I made that video and I
didn't know it was gonna go on the front
of every website it's not that well made
I probably would have done a better job
if somebody had told me that but they
didn't so why would I disable god mode
no cap in my ass okay
what's all weapons Idaho no cap in my
ass
Idaho okay
no cap in my ass am i dead I'm dead no
cap in my ass
Ida oh I doubt hope no cap and Myers did
not work oh it did no I didn't it make
shake
maybe I spelled ass wrong I could just
go over to a hundred percent health
girls world Clarisse this is so weird
in a Bergamo no cap in my ass oh I want
to be like heaven
I remember typing that in was that in a
different game I remember I want to be
like heaven
I wanna be like Evan yes
save save ooh all right what weapons
we've got here we got the the flare gun
we got big dirty shotgun we got oh hello
Tommy gun great we got what the [ __ ] is
that a rocket launcher yep we got
dynamite we all that's right the high
school special aerosol can oh hey what's
up check out this street aerosol kind of
have yeah that's just like what happened
in school yeah okay I'm gonna go with
either lightning gun or grenade launcher
oh it's like a mixture too - right what
the [ __ ] wasps I don't know what that is
Oh Buddha doll oh that dude oh that's
freaking out oh this is great who do you
share these people I'm sorry it's just
that I have the voodoo doll and whatever
I pointed I guess look at that why is
nobody done this before
this is tremendous this is what Guybrush
Threepwood should have done I ran out of
Voodoo pins eat it eat it eat it eat it
eat it eat it
everyone died I'm in in everyone dying
mood right now everyone should look at
all this [ __ ] blown up alright okay I
know that's not that impressive now but
when this was happening back in drink
diggity seven it's pretty cool I guess
they took the stuff that has nothing to
do with your actual Joe John person and
the thing about duke nukem was that it
had like stuff to you could interact
with there wasn't necessarily anything
to do with killing people like pool
tables urinals stuff like that and kind
of blood kind of just kind of expanded
on that a bit add lots more like
destructible stuff as well that was like
incidental destructible self not not
like are they fighting with each other
like not like exploding barrels and
stuff you know they're fighting with
each other
she thought I've accident do it do it
don't make me use the skull thing which
I don't know what it does yet alright
[ __ ] everyone
so check out my skill this is why the
[ __ ] stole 50 cents go no ice I think
I'm murdering everyone I found a secret
what is it
oh it's basic oh [ __ ] oh why is it dark
I'm not locked in the air with you
you're locked in here with me also there
was no one there I want to kill one more
person with a skull take it okey got it
moon key how whatever all right I think
I'm all I'm all blooded out
unfortunately we have to cut this short
because I have to catch myself a flight
out of here
I'm heading to Ireland why are people
screaming
what the [ __ ] these the Moke voices in
my head
oh no it's these [ __ ] die great
alright
blood from monolith games available on
gog.com for the low low price of a $5.99
that's when random encounter thank you
very much for hanging out today I'll be
back in a couple of weeks yeah if you
want to see what I'm up to in Ireland
then I guess you could come with me
yeah but that's probably not possible
yeah so if I do run into in Ireland
hello and let's get drinks another wise
internet where well I'll see you in a
couple of weeks Gamescom see you there